the original animated version of 101
Dalmatians was a huge influence on me as
a kid I saw it when I was
and what Ken Anderson and Walt Perrigo
did in that film I thought was so
beautiful and I I continue to watch that
film we watched it several times for
ratatouille for the color styling and
how they treated a European city and was
just beautiful and so my favorite moment
in that is cruella de Vil's house
interior and especially her bedroom they
just went all out it's like brilliant
pink and very impressionistic over this
sort of Victorian Edwardian backdrop of
ornament that was drawn in black line
the scene in ratatouille were Remmy
climbs from he doesn't know he's in
Paris climbs from the sewer up through
the walls of a Paris apartment house and
views different vignettes in each
apartment and then winds up on the
rooftop overlooking the city of Paris
where he realizes he's in the food
capital of the world and so I I loved
that moment and Brad Birds
conceptualized that whole path of Remy
up through the through the building and
it you know continues to be something
I'm really proud of and I still get a
kick out of seeing it
you